ces défis ciel après 39 ans où je vais
travailler parce que 7 jours sur 7 39
ans ça nous ramène en 1989 montréal
venait de perdre son statut de métropole
du canada au profit de toronto le
canadien s'était fait battre en séries
pour la première fois par les nordiques
la reine rapatrier officiellement la
constitution
j'étais marvin rotrand faisait sa
première campagne à 31 entre
l'administration de rapides avec l'inde
aurait en 1982 jean est battu et il sera
réélu à chaque fois dans snowdon et
verra passer cette mère et une mairesse
parmi ces accomplissements l'ouverture
des micros à l'hôtel de ville en 1986
nous avons la première chasse créer une
période des questions projets citoyens
aient accès au sénat mais ce qu'il
reprochait au conseil municipal des
années 80 c'était surtout son manque de
représentativité montre havrais a
largement demandé que marianne
reconnaître que c'est une ville
multiculturelle et multiraciale quand je
suis arrivé tout le monde est blanche à
l'hôtel nouvelle dont se souvenir de
moments savoureux lui qui s'opposaient
aux fusions municipales pioche celui-ci
jeu souviennent les fans que j'avais été
quand j'ai prouvé que l'application des
pierres brutes avec 50000 non fusion
forcée
ils ont vérifié 45 1454 signature et ils
en ont éliminé la moitié est seulement
7000 nombre dans la même écriture re
coté à 1 station métro avec beaucoup
d'honneur à quai et s'ils vendent ces
années en tant qu'élu indépendant qui
l'ont tenu loin des lignes de parti il
finira son mandat en tant qu'élu de
l'opposition beaucoup de résonance avec
moi parce que mon travail pendant 40 ans
ce grand fidèle du conseil municipal
s'inquiète d'en manquer des bribes il
tente de se connecter au milieu du parc
il lui reste encore d'émotion à défendre
avant de laisser définitivement la
politique derrière lui ici mathieu prost
radio canada montréal